hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the defeated world rap a
championship it's day two and it's Game
six shocker Madera vs. young Christophe
Duda and in round five if you've been
following the coverage so far we've
checked out the game oh it is a
ferocious versus young feast of Duda
where do that showed just how how strong
he is with the white piece with the
black pieces stopping the the seemingly
unstoppable furiosa but now he faces a
member of the elite Roger Mamedov so
let's see how he how he handles that so
without further ado with the white
pieces Mahmoud Arif opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 c4 we have g6 Knight
to f3 and nightgood f3 and Bishop to g7
the Kings Indian defense is on the board
and here we have g3 something that is
becoming very popular nowadays how to
counter this setup we have c6 Bishop to
g2 and now d5 and in the live coverage
Peter like oh who is just the the the
most amazing guy he really knows
everything and he is extremely strong I
mentioned that Quinta b3 is the the only
move that basically makes sense nowadays
as all of the other moves have been
depleted and this is the only way to
look for advantage wood white so just
thought you'd want to know that so we
have castles castles and the Queen to b6
now offering the Queen trade and the
Knight to c3 both players wanted the
other guy to capture on b6 or b3 so well
either this either White gets to do at
the open and the semi open a file or
black as the semi open a file rook to d8
and an outer ship to d2 we have Bishop
to e6 putting pressure on c4 and now
well not that sorry Knight to a4
attacking the black queen and forcing
the trade on B 3 so we have Queen
Catherine b38 captures and now Knight B
to d7 you don't have time for a slow
move because nice the b6 would win the
room you cannot capture the night well
you can you would have to but then the
rook captures rook so we have Knight bt7
making room for the rook also now the
rooks are guarding each other and now
rook F 2 c1
we have Knight to e4 all been played
before
not allowing of course this
Bishop to b4 attacking the e7 pawn and
pink to f8 and now III and there is a
one game where if I was played but here
we have h6 it is a new move by Judah so
it is as I move 14 that we have a
completely new game so this is how mama
DRF treats the position he first goes
knife to d2 threatens just to win a pawn
on e4 and do that replies with a 5 so
this is something Duda prepared and now
it's mom you have to move mom you're off
says okay I wanted to capture on e4
either way with Knight captures on e4
and now capturing and b4 is well it's
quite questionable because after the
knight moves will captures captures for
example we have a trade on a1 and now
well something well the bishop is under
attack you kind of don't want this to be
doubled up but you don't really have a
chance you Bishop back to see a to
defend the point isn't isn't all that
great then you no longer have proper
defense of the d5 pawn you allow rook
the a8 and it's it would just be a
better position for white so here
instead b6 would have to be played
captures captures messing up the black's
pawn structure and now you can start
well either you can capture here right
away or you can start infiltrating with
the rook but it is thought that white
would have the advantage there so
instead I'm not going for this guy we
have D capture Sonny for better back the
t1 and now well your pawn is hanging you
defended with f5 and now mommy Yara
doesn't want to see b5 on the board so
Bishop back to f1 gaining control of the
b v square and now bishop the f7 making
room for the for the e pawn to be pushed
we have B for getting rid of the double
beep on and also opening up the a file
with a capture son before Bishop
captures now the e7 point is pinned and
rook to a 6 now are taking control of b6
also perhaps having ideas of doubling up
on the a file with c5 grabbing control
of the b6 square and now rook the a7
seemingly a waiting move just waiting
for a white to drop that night to b6
and trade rooks on the a file which is
exactly what my major of does he was
Knight b6 we have rook captures an a1
rook captures and Knight captures and b6
with pawn captures and b6 again doubling
points on the B file but now it is it is
actually a very strong point and here
Duda has to go for worship to be a
bishop to d5 the game continues and it's
perfectly equal however dude I thought
that he doesn't have to do it right away
he prefers not to make his bishop a pawn
he goes Kingdom yet he wants to improve
the position of his King push 'if I've
bust open the e-file and claim that he
he's at least equal but this doesn't
really work here mama D off please rook
to e7 and now you have problems because
now well you you can have to defend with
Bishop to d5 because if you go rook to
b8 then white has a very clean way to
end the game but feel free to pause the
video and try to find this well winning
move for white well I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding this move in a line that
never actually happened and for those
who just want enjoyed show its Bishop to
a6 just threatening to win this pawn
then you have a passed pawn and b6
that's the winning and if you capture
the bishop then the bishop still attacks
is seven just to rug characters if you
go to a faith you go in front of the
bishop then all sorts of nasty
discoveries become possible like Ruby 7
check fall by rook captures NB a and if
you go here it's just real captures this
Bishop then this Bishop will fall as
well since you don't have a good Square
for him to go to a chain and just rock
f8 checked except the rook completely
winning for white so Duda has to go to
d5 with the idea that okay if route
captures then you can push c5 attacking
the bishop and the rook but Mamedov is
not in a hurry mama Daryl just plays
Bishop c5 it doesn't allow a black to
push d5 also the point is nicely
protected now do the plays rook to d7
but the same move again applies so I'm
not gonna ask you to pause the video
because you already saw it
Bishop to a6 again threatening to just
win the b7 pawn and here we have B
characters on a6 because b7 and
you cannot defend this if you've logged
in just Rock a8
so after b7 with rook captures giving up
the exchange rook a person b7 and Bishop
to f6 now defending the e7 phone and now
it's a rook and Bishop against a bishop
pair and well a bishop area is is a very
strong weapon however in an endgame
orokin bishop is always a rockin bishop
most of the times so crook to be sexy
going after the a6 pawn now there's no
way to defend it because if you do this
didn't lose the c6 pawn we're King to d7
and now rook captures on a6 Bishop to c4
shifting the bishop over to b5 with rook
to a7 check kink the e6 and now rook the
c7 going after the c6 pawn there should
be five and now b3 not allowing this
point to remain a target because a
member wants the bust opened the
position with it b5
we have g5 by black and now d5 it's it's
really an exciting move because if you
capture then after before you that you
have created a passed beep beep on now
you're just gonna kick away the light
square bishop and then start pushing
your past point to victory so we can
capture some d5 but now Bishop captures
on e7 white is up material so basically
it's always a principled decision when
you're rough material you want to trade
down as much as possible
there should be five attacks the rook
looked the b7 with Bishop to e2 and now
h4 with f4 for Duda now comes H captors
and g5 h captures and Bishop Tadros and
g5 grabbing upon F captures and g3 but
now Bishop to f4 Mamedov is of course
very confident that he can win this G
captures an f2 check King captures and
Bishop to d3 now as the light square
bishop is under attack but now just the
Bishop captures and King captures so
it's both there's two pawns but still
it's a look against the bishop and it
will be very interesting to see how
momager of does a king he won with c5
and now keep the d2 with King to d6 and
now King to c3 the Shabak the e2 and now
rook to g7
we have king to d5 and now rook to g2
taking away squares from the light
square bishop bishop
one rook F 2 and Bishop back to b5
we have kinked a b2 now going to a the
ring King to c6 and now rope the f6
check we have came back to d5 and rook
to f5 check King to c6 now the King be
stuck guarding the c5 pawn and rooked f8
now we have Russia back to e 2 and King
to a3 we have King to be 5 and now rook
to f6 taking away well put all all of
the squares from the black king with
Bishop to d3 and now rook to e6 and now
you really don't have all that many
moves if you move the bishop you lose
the pawn if you move the king then
rookie 5 is winning just you threaten
the pawn and after King b6 just B 4 is
enough for a win because after a
captures captures this is winning you
just well whatever you do doesn't really
matter if your repeat moves just king c3
you'll repeat moves king d4 and now any
move you just capture the pawn and you
win because this endgame is of course
winning for white so here do the tries
Bishop c2 but we have pink tabby to with
pretty much the same plan Bishop d3 King
to c3 King to a5 and now we get rook to
d6 we have Russia back to e 2 and not
rook the d5 the position is now similar
to the one we've already shown if in b5
it's even worse because you just went
upon the the c5 point is pin so after
Luke d5 King b6 but now of course mom
your please b4 and that's it we've see
character screen captures King to c6
we have rook to d4 and Bishop to d3 King
to c3 we have Kings to c5 and came to d2
and now as the black King cannot gain
control well the defense of the e4 pawn
it was in this position that Yankee
Doodle resigned because the White King
is just going to well not that way but
he he's just going to reach DF 4 squared
take the e4 pawn and that's of course a
win again game for white so after King D
to do the resigned and a well-deserved
victory for soccer mom job as a patrol
echo said it was one of the positions
that gave white immense trouble how to
break through and
mom you have found some more poison to
be used against the this line of the
Kings Indian so I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Stephen green Leon
and mark sigue Alessio potaka as Simon
Sevilla and Jill shredder for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Sarah
think of for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing for the next two days the
coverage of the feeder world rapid M
blitz championship so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and don't forget to be
a part of the subscribers video thank
you all I will see you soon and well we
already mentioned it have an excellent
rest of your day